all of the tmg studios content is in one
place every podcast every episode every
bonus episode all ad free and you can
access it for just six dollars a month
with a membership to tmgstudios.tv
anyways man you jack harlow single
yeah there's yep
yep what do you think
um there is one one line i really like
yeah i got it
do you know the one i'm talking about
i think so yeah yeah it's a good line
sweet
sweet
you know all about that man three sweets
that's part of your program that's true
that's why that's what you're saying
really sweet
i'd say it's like first on my gym
playlist you know yeah yeah no that's
between swigs of
horse semen
sweet sweet sweet semen
three sweets
let it be known sweet pineapple juice i
give her sweet sweet sweet semen
man i crawled out of my skin when i
first heard that line yeah
no i was like man this song's been going
crazy viral it's not even out yet [ __ ]
yeah
and then like thursday at 9 00 p.m i'm
like oh [ __ ] it's on my release yeah
listen to it
yes good
i'm liking that sweet sweet sweet semen
it's the fourth line in the verse yeah
yeah so
it's a pretty it's it's jarring because
it's a very abrupt way to let you know
that this song is not for you yeah
that's very true you walked into ladies
night yeah that's very true yeah you're
just dancing in your room you're like
hey wait what
what's up oh i'm
oh yeah let me take these off
whoops
whoops
your boy's like yo put on that new jack
ah it's not for us man
it's not our song
he'll get us on the next one this ain't
this one's not for us yeah
he's he's out there you know [ __ ] the
world so yeah i mean
i saw some tweet or something that was
like you know he's not gonna stop until
there's no more girls left yeah
i was like yeah that's that's pretty apt
yeah that description of what he's doing
because every dude is like ah this this
sucks this was a miss for me this does
not hit and then
you have to understand he's taking all
50 of the world for himself yeah
i just i mean like i like the chorus
yeah
i don't mind like the sample is
incredible yeah the chorus it's like he
says like four words in the chorus and
it's still like damn this is good
and then
rappers just do that [ __ ] i feel like
they do it on purpose what
like can i out swag just
the worst thing that i could possibly
say like the most unlistenable word
sure how can i prove that i'm
[ __ ] cool yeah is by saying the most
unlistenable word and still like make
people listen to it yeah and vibe out to
it and sing it yeah semen
semen yeah sweet sweet sweet
[Music]
for you
for girls too oh who knows when have you
ever heard a girl
say give me some of that semen
i think if jack is saying it i think you
know i think they get hypnotized right
like
you know you can seam in wherever you
want yeah they just eyes start swirling
and they're like sweet sweet sweet semen
sweet sweet sweet semen
it's the same feeling i have when i see
a go-kart
yeah right
[Laughter]
it should have been readily apparent for
all dudes in the first five seconds that
that song was not for dudes
because uh
like the way he's just kind of
ad-libbing the chorus
but
really when he said i can put you in
first class that's when every guy should
have been like
i don't think he's talking to him no no
he is he's talking about a boy's trip oh
that's true yeah yeah yeah that was a
frank guy in you exactly oh hell yeah
jack's taking us to cabo bro
let's go
is that private jet that's what you're
talking about right i could put you in
first class dude you're such a boy jack
that's the homie right there loves
singing that line bro he's always
looking he always puts me in first class
he's thinking to me dude yeah he thought
of me when he wrote he thought of me
yeah yeah the semen line
i don't know if that's for me i don't
know if that's for me
you know he could be talking about like
tequila
tequila kind of tastes like nuts
just a frag guy justifying in his head
how do you know that man
what
i don't i don't i just assume
i'm just assuming
if i were
siemens tastes bad right
like i wouldn't taste it
ever so i'm assuming tequila doesn't
taste the best but you know people like
tequila pineapple so yeah
no i think i think it's for us still
dude yeah yeah no because he meant like
cloud9 like he wasn't on like angus
clouds
dude
it wasn't honest nine bro like
he's on like cloud and loud like he's
and angus is his boy you know and i
think i could be boys with angus too
yeah
he seems like a chiller
like angus definitely reminds us of
people we know yeah
no it's for it's for us dude for us
[Laughter]
for sure
ladies i want to know is that semen line
was that as jarring to you as it was for
me i think it's i think it's pretty
jarring for a lot of people
[Music]
it makes me not want to play the song
again
it's a it's a tough one to play out loud
yeah
i can't i can't hear that
sweets like just
one sweet
would have been bad enough
yes the tension he does yeah sweet sweet
sweet where what's he gonna semen
oh no
what are some other like really
unlistenable words
panties that's a bad one for me
like yeah you hit the t on that panties
yeah and t's yeah panties oh like what
about like uh
favio foreign that song where he goes
[ __ ] in pooping oh that's super
listenable [ __ ] what are you talking
about
yeah it really is actually that's super
listen with that all the time yeah just
that online i sing that all the time on
loop bro forget the [ __ ] song pooping
bring that up real fast yeah 504 just
search [ __ ] and pooping
no search [ __ ] and poop in jersey remix
yeah that's the one i'm talking about
yeah some some kid like he made one
and then i like tweeted out i'm like
dude can you make this the full he's
like got you like a few hours later oh
yeah we've already talked about this
yeah but you know just run it
let's go
[Music]
yeah yeah okay okay man i heard a line
the other day i was like huh
[Laughter]
which one i can't remember oh you know
one kodak got playing for in his new
album he was like
he said something like i love my baby
daddy
and i heard it and i was like
wait huh
and i ran it back a few times i'm like
ed
is this someone like not getting here
that i typed a line in twitter and so
many people were like
bro did kodak just say he loves his baby
daddy
it wasn't even anyone being mean like
everyone was just like whoa
what do you mean are you mean what does
that mean
it's just a head [ __ ]
head [ __ ] of a line
you